hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll and as this episode is being
released in late july 2022 there's a lot
of news stories going on around interest
rates going up and the desire to curb
inflation there's a whole bunch of
reasons why dealing with global supply
chains wars a whole bunch of things
going on this podcast will be about none
of those things i'm sure these things
are very very important but they are of
the moment and they might go away we
here at minescape are about of eternity
we want to know the truths underlying
what is going on so this podcast is
however about interest rates and in fact
it's kind of
something i was reluctant to get into
today's guest john quiggin is a very
respected economist at the university of
queensland in australia the accent will
be a dead giveaway right away
and he's written a very interesting
books about markets and how they both
succeed and how they fail so i invited
him on the podcast and he says love to
talk about markets but what i really
want to talk about are interest rates
i was skeptical since i know nothing
about interest rates and they do seem a
little bit you know down in the in the
mess of policy and so forth but it's
interesting because number one there's a
phenomenon going on where interest rates
globally are way low there are many
countries that accounting for inflation
are going with zero interest rates in
the government's lending to certain
preferred lenders and so forth why is
that this is something very different
than has been going on before
but also it actually does kind of
resonate with the intellectual themes
that we talk about here on mindscape
because what do you mean by an interest
rate
i have a dollar i'm gonna give you a
dollar if you promise to give me back a
dollar and five cents a year from now
five percent interest rate okay
so basically you're trading money for
time in some sense to me i would rather
have the dollar five a year from now and
you would rather have the dollar right
now that is the basis of the idea of
interest rates so it's involving a
prediction of what the future is and a
sort of evaluation of where you are
right now which is actually quite
interesting and you want to know you
know why would anyone do that maybe
because you just need something right
now maybe you need a house and you don't
have enough money for it or a car so you
get a loan and you'll pay back more
later because you've commuted a lot more
money
but if you're a business
maybe you want that money now because
you want to keep up your factory or you
want to do some expansion of your
manufacturing capabilities that was a
very traditional reason why there were
government loans and therefore interest
rates but
john's point is that the world is
changing
and the kinds of companies the kinds of
large corporations that dominate the
global marketplace right now are
increasingly information based right
google and apple and facebook and what
have you and these are companies that
don't need major overhauls of their
manufacturing capabilities their
manufacturing capabilities are kind of
tiny compared to their value and this is
a big reason he claims why
interest rates are much lower because
the demand is just not there for these
kinds of loans the modern world is
running on a different kind of
model than we ran on just a few decades
ago and that's not only intrinsically
interesting by itself but it relates to
the fact that information
which is what google and facebook etc
are selling as their stock and trade is
in some sense or could be thought of as
a public good
right it's not like i have this piece of
information and therefore nobody else
can have it
we have a common vested interest in
information being spread and being
spread accurately right we want to fight
misinformation and disinformation and so
forth so i'm not sure that we have the
solutions here today but it relates to
interest rates in a very interesting way
the the kind this is the kind of problem
that sneaks up on us
a kind of spin-off that we didn't
necessarily anticipate when the internet
and global information
economy became such an important thing
so if nothing else
food for thought
in terms of how we should be thinking
about structuring our economy going
forward which is an important thing to
do so let's go
[Music]
john quiggin welcome to the mindscape
podcast hey glad to be here
so this is going to be one of those
episodes where unlike when i'm talking
to a physicist and i can sometimes
play dumb
i can ask questions about like what is a
black hole and i really know the answer
here i'm going to be asking questions i
just don't know the answer to at all
economics is well beyond my expertise
but that's why i started the podcast so
i can ask questions like this so let me
start with you know some of the most
basic ones that have been lurking in my
mind for for decades um
markets we're going to be talking about
markets a lot but sometimes i get the
impression that people talk about
markets as if they're
an invention an innovation of modernity
like weren't there markets in the
ancient world weren't there free markets
in mesopotamia or china or whatever
well certainly i think markets
in one formula have been around for a
very long time uh as soon as you get uh
as soon as you get money
and you really have markets in the
modern sense and that's thousands and
thousands of years ago and even before
that you certainly had trade barter and
so forth um there's an interesting
question which david graber
a woman an anthropologist looked at of
uh there's a standard creation story
where we invented money to make
markets work better he argues until
money was all about debt about paying
your taxes to the king or chief or
whatever it was uh and then came to be
used in transactions as well but
whatever the story markets are not are
not new uh there are a sort of
and it hasn't been designed they've sort
of emerged
uh but they're also not free yeah they
rely on a whole bunch of rules and
conventions uh which vary from place to
place which which
depend on what you can trade and of
course what you own well in your book
that you have that i have right here
next to me economics in two lessons why
markets work so well and why they can
fail so badly you take kind of what i
what i take to be
um
not the most common way of defining what
a market is in terms of opportunity
costs uh could you explain how you
explained that why you chose that well
you you had that way of talking about it
oh yeah so the the opportunity cost of
something is what you have to give up to
get it and that applies both for
individuals and societies so um
and that applies to all kinds of choices
uh the time i'm spending talking to you
i could be spending
uh improving my score on a video game or
something like that right so time in
particular benjamin franklin says time
is money and while that is that very
money specific and therefore the point
is uh because everything you spend you
could be doing something else the best
available alternative is the opportunity
cost and
markets
make that very clear to us that
when we buy something
we forego
something else we could buy or we or we
will go saving or we've got a leisure
that we could have taken more time off
and not made the money we needed to buy
the
uh by the good in question all those
things
at the margin are
opportunity costs and the reason i focus
on this
uh
is i think when hey that we shouldn't be
talking about money which is a standard
point that economists always get upset
about that they think we're all about
money and we're not
but also
in terms of our undergraduate training
we do a lot of stuff doing little supply
and demand diagrams and calculating
areas actually since you're a physicist
so i got the idea of this partly from
feynman who sort of in his
uh i think
qed book says look if you want to
actually do the calculations you need to
learn all this complicated physical
maths if you understand if you want to
understand what's going on
you know here's the story and here's the
waves and the particles and why why if
you just add up the probabilities right
uh you can get the right answer so it's
always been my view that if people
understood opportunity costs properly
and they understand most of the issues
in policy that um
all the time people are saying why can't
we have everything and the answers you
can't you're always making choices and
the reason why economists don't like to
be accused of only talking about money
is because they think of themselves
you'll correct me if i'm wrong as having
sort of a much more general conception
of making choices under conditions of
scarcity or something like that
absolutely that's the core of it and
indeed
yeah in the ideal view of at least a
large group of economists not all
money is just this unfortunate thing
that
complicates everything you know that i
mean it's necessary to make the
transactions work but but uh it's as
they say it's available and the object
is to pierce that fail and and see the
real transactions going underneath now
that's not every economy some economists
have a much more you know i think money
is much more important than that and and
uh but but certainly
the the classical view is it's the real
transactions are going on that matter uh
the money is just a way of keeping score
okay so if we have internalized the idea
of an opportunity cost well actually let
me back up maybe we haven't internalized
that idea like how do i know what all of
the other things i could be doing are or
the value of all those other things i
mean this is clearly giving me a lot
more credit than i deserve
and indeed in the second part of the
book my i make a whole bunch of points
of this kind that markets
are presenters with these things but
unless we know
unless we know everything that in
picture of the market choices unless we
know everything that's available in the
market what its price is
uh we can all get the same price uh then
they don't work in the ideal way that uh
of ensuring that everything
they're always making the best choice
available to us if we don't know what
the price of other things are for
example we might have to bargain and
things we
face uncertainty about what we'll have
in the future
and our own capacity to understand these
things is bounded i suppose that's
something that's something i'm keen on
i suppose to sermonize a little bit here
when economists talk about bounded
rationality they mostly talk
in a kind of way of people doing silly
things it's easy to point to mistakes
people make
um
and yeah that they do this when they
shouldn't but what really matters is
everybody is boundly rational the
smartest person in the world can't
unders you can't understand an uptime
fraction of the of the things that are
relevant their choices
uh and so we're always being surprised
by things we're unaware of in the past
and so in that sense there's always
there's always limits to
how world markets do
in saying
here's this choice you make but you're
giving up that if they work perfectly
there would be no free lunches left on
the table everything would be smooth
good so yeah i do want to get to i kind
of want to roughly follow the
organizational principles of the book
where we first give the pro market uh
happy lesson and then we'll then we'll
talk about the failures later but
okay if we imagine that people are
pretty darn good reasoners and have all
the information etc
the idea is that the market is a way of
finding an equilibrium is that fair
between what the sellers have and what
the buyers want
yes so we all want we all want things we
all want to consume things and we all
want to
we all have something we can offer
off in return for those things
and
it's the prices both determine and
reflect the opportunity costs that we we
face so so when we face these prices we
um
that's the opportunity because we raise
the wage we can get for doing more work
the things we can buy without the choice
we make at the same time collectively
all our choices determine what those
prices are right and working smoothly uh
working smoothly we get this outcome
where
there are no free lunches left on the
table there's no way of
making
me better off without somebody else
worse off uh the converse of that is
there's an infinite range of those
situations any of them with the right
initial allocation of property rights
could be a competitive equilibrium okay
and again to sort of give the pro-market
point of view i did have uh henry
farrell on the podcast uh your
co-blogger at crookedtimber which i'll
give a plug for one of the few old
school blogs that is still just going
strong like people are still posting
we're carrying on for
sure impressive i had my own personal
blog which uh is even rarer i think a 20
year old individual blog very very good
um so
but one of the things that henry talked
about is
democracy as a problem-solving measure a
problem-solving mechanism and he
compared it contrasted it with markets
so talk a little bit about this
conception of
how we can think of a market as a way of
solving a puzzle or doing a calculation
as a physicist might say it yeah so so
the market really says let's
take has given a bunch of rules
including who owns what and who can who
can trade and sell what
uh and um
and then ask the question you know what
should we produce and who should consume
it and so
so that's uh that's what the market
market solves and the important thing is
if you compare it to
central planning
uh yeah that's an incredibly difficult
problem that if you try and work out how
many pencils we should have there's a
famous
uh famous book i talk at fabulous
article i'll talk about about the pencil
the vast majority of people engaged in
the process of producing a pencil have
no idea about it certainly have no
thought of who will ultimately consume
the pencil
if they see
a demand for more lumber
right they have no idea where that
demand is coming from they just know
that
there are more orders coming in and they
should
produce more trees
the other side of that i suppose
skipping slightly order is
we can come to
uh huge amounts of this process depend
on choices that are made
uh
democratically or perhaps
undemocratically uh prior to uh prior to
the market transactions taking place
right but but but still you know if
we're still giving the the pro market
point of view here i mean it is a
remarkably effective way of answering
this particular kind of question you
know um
it's called it's an emergence phenomenon
right it's no one person knows the right
thing to do but the collective wisdom of
everybody figures it out
yes and and that's sort of something
which it took a long while for people to
work out for a long time people thought
in terms of the just price and so forth
that
and of course
although markets always existed uh
society is
much more marketized now than it was
in the past if you were
a person
at most points in the past you worked in
agriculture because everybody did
uh you probably had a lord you paid them
stuff
uh you had had little bits of money and
bartered you know you went to blacksmith
to get your horse shot and things like
that but
uh
things didn't change much so if the
price of something changed a lot the
answer was well something must be bad
here yeah and similarly you uh similarly
if you dealt with a merchant it wasn't
it seemed as if the merchant was taking
something for nothing um
somebody else would produce the you know
what the cloth or whatever it is the
merchant brought to your place you paid
for it somehow you paid a lot more than
the burst the person producing the cloth
got the merchant took it that seemed
very problematic yeah and at the risk of
just being repetitive i think this is
sort of intellectually for me
a profound fact uh i guess it was
discussed on crooked timber on the blog
in that uh book event you had talking
about red plenty which was a sort of
science fiction novel imagining if they
really tried to play in the economy all
the way using all the science and et
cetera we could uh cosma chalizzi i
guess made the point that it is
literally beyond our calculational
capacity
to
correctly figure out ahead of time how
to price things in a society better than
the market could do
well certainly certainly comprehensively
that's true as we'll see of course there
are plenty of cases where the market
gets it wrong we can see it gets it
wrong and we know why it gets it wrong
and we can fix things but if we try if
we i think
the dream of central planning was the
last gasp of that idea of the just price
that we could work out what everybody
wanted maybe they tell us we just
produced the stuff without the need for
without need for market uh people just
do what they do what they should and
that's i think
a problem in a bunch of a bunch of
context that even if you're trying to
even if you supposed people who are
perfectly everybody perfectly won't do
the right thing
you know you say should i study to be a
doctor
or an engineer
how can i possibly tell right and uh the
phrase just price brings me to another
question i wanted to have uh the just
price phrase sort of
makes me think that or makes us think
that there is some correct price for
things and you don't need the market to
set it and it's almost a normative thing
right it's almost a value judgment but
yes in many contexts now it's the other
way around people
go for the market or argue for market
economies not just on the basis of being
more efficient but on on values right
like it's the right thing to do like any
deviation from that is somehow morally
wrong there are there are p i don't put
words in your mouth it's not your point
of view but there are people who
at least give that impression yeah
yeah i would say yeah i mean
neoliberalism is a
much misused phrase but it does have a
core meaning and a part of that
is the notion of valorizing market
processes
and
taking very strong presumption in favor
of them even when there seems to be good
reasons in the past for for opposing
them and particularly particularly in
relation to financial markets which are
the most abstract complex distrusted of
markets
uh
and i think as it turns out distrusted
for good reasons
and so um
and so so so particularly if you go back
to the 1990s
uh the idea that financial markets would
get things right when others couldn't
possibly do so i had a great deal of
popularity and certainly certainly it's
it's still not crazy but on the other
hand when you look at something like
cryptocurrency
or the global financial crisis right you
conclude
that
that the bounds on rationality the kind
of rationality that's required to make
central planning work
also is needed if you were to avoid
fairly catastrophic outcomes in
financial markets yeah i mean i just
wanted to get on the table uh the pro
market argument because it is kind of an
interesting collective problem-solving
mechanism but then
it's very clear that there's a whole
bunch of issues and then the the
complicated part seems to me
which issues are more important and how
do you solve them right um i have one
very basic philosophical question right
from the start which is does it even
make sense
to
compare different kinds of goods in the
way that
your definition of the of the market
working in terms of price equaling
equaling opportunity cost makes sense
like it seems like it's a presupposition
that we can always place a monetary
value on things is that a presupposition
we should worry about or is that
necessary well i think let's let's again
leave the money out okay there's a
presupposition i guess
that in you know at least in a large
sphere of action we can judge
which of two things we want right and
our choices are going to be better than
any other choice
and
and if we express that choice in the
market by offering to trade that that
will get the right outcome so
uh so i think that's
yeah now of course
that presumption isn't always it isn't
accepted in any society globally if i
decide that yeah i mean looking at a
rational theory i could decide that well
i'm advanced in years cocaine won't kill
me very quickly sounds pretty cool i
would like some cocaine uh in my society
that's not a choice that people think i
should make
that's absolutely true but i guess here
here's what i have in mind um i'm
currently house hunting
and there's this famous issue where you
know if you have a house that you want
to buy and that has a certain price but
you get into a bidding war
and it gets to the point where it's just
more expensive than you're willing to
pay right so
you make the rational choice of not
buying that house and
in some sense you shouldn't feel bad
about that
you you're not spending too much money
you're doing the rational thing but real
human beings always do feel bad in that
situation so yeah is there some mismatch
between our intuitive psychology and and
how we are being modeled in this
situation well this i mean i this is
that people aren't
calculating machines that some of these
things and all transactions involve a
social element
uh you know perhaps you have a spouse
and you have to
i have to explain to spouse yeah sorry
we didn't get that house we agreed that
we weren't getting any more than this
and as your agent i stuck to that and
maybe yeah so there's that collective
aspect to it uh there's also
also some also different transactions
were different i mean every house is
different every buyer is different
it isn't a market yet it isn't a market
of the same kind as as the supermarket
we go down and say
here six bands of yogurt which one will
i right
which one will i buy will they not buy
it at all and have ice cream instead uh
there's this one house and and it's of
course impossible yeah impossible to
till
uh the par is not taken if you had
bought this house until the other one
uh
you know what what the counterfactual
have been so so yeah i think
it's uh
people understand that kind of thing but
certainly this model what most people do
i think uh
um i um there's a famous economist who
talks about the deadweight loss of
christmas and um
and
it says you know well cash will be
better and it doesn't go the whole hot
because if you thought of this correct
thought this correctly you just say look
let's all work out in the family what
we're going to give and get
and just
hand it
it's good to lose it the people the net
players put money in the people who are
net gators take it out
we don't have any of this pair what
pairwise me giving you someone you're
giving me some etc so but yeah there's
there's obviously elements
uh elements that are not rational and of
course most advertising large sections
are what works that way it tries to
associate
good feelings with the product you're
consuming or possibly discontent with
what you currently have
in complicated way and i guess the other
quasi-philosophical issue i wanted to
bring up before we get to the failures
of the market is this idea of
equilibrium because the discussion
really reminds me of a discussion going
on right now in physics where you know
we invented thermodynamics over 150
years ago and it was for a long time
based on the idea of equilibrium between
different physical systems and
everything else was sort of an annoyance
and within the last 15 20 years we've
had a revolution uh focusing on
non-equilibrium phenomena in
thermodynamics and statistical mechanics
because most of the world is outside of
equilibrium so is uh economics also
undergoing that revolution or do they
always have that idea or is it yet to
happen
so good question i mean i mean because
we're always accused of physics envy and
this equilibrium notion uh that we took
from physics that's at the core of that
yeah plus a general taste for matthew's
side of stuff so there's i think two
kinds of issues one is the equilibrium
i've been talking about of a market
equilibrium and we've always you know we
it's it's a
a long running source so we've always
wanted a theory of outfit out of
equilibrium adjustment to equilibrium
never had a really good one but the
other issue which is
more modern uh going back to 1950 is
nash equilibrium in games yeah so we
have we have there's been huge
development of game theory which
generally undermines the certainties of
the certainties of economics because
essentially the dirty secret of game
theory is anything can happen yeah
in economics and game theory it's called
the folk theorem uh and
a lot and so so we have this thing where
we if we play a game many times
essentially anything
anything can happen unless it's so bad
for a player that they can walk away
from the game and say i'm just not going
to play
and in trying to
narrow down refine the set of
equilibrium
a huge question is what do people think
about what will happen outside
equilibrium so in that sense we've
actually made
this question of what happens outside
equilibrium is crucial in game theory
which is now a really big part of
economics in in terms of competitive
general equilibrium we haven't made the
same progress but
i suppose the other thing is in
principle the link between the two is we
should have an equilibrium theory which
includes oligopoly and monopoly that
means gain theory and that kind of
equilibrium
depends
what the executive outcome we get
depends critically on what people think
about what will happen outside
equilibrium yeah i'm just talking out
loud now and this might be all nonsense
but my
informal impression is that economics
has taken on very seriously the idea
that people are not always rational
right that's you know an important thing
to think of but there's another way to
deviate from equilibrium which is just
random fluctuations right uh there's
some unpredictability in the system and
that's where the physics progress has
been
made is there a lot of work being done
uncharacterized
we might be ahead of you there because
shaking hand equilibrium was sort of a
big thing back in the 50s and 60s the
path the question of equilibrium is
what happened
what happens if you and and indeed
stability of equilibrium of course which
i suppose was in physics as well
i was a big issue in general equilibrium
theory but this question of uh what do
you know if i'm in an equilibrium where
i'm making the best response to you what
do i think will happen if you change a
little bit if you if you make a little
mistake for example yeah
do we just go back to the original part
do we do something very like the
original path was a bit different so
that's all that in the game theoretic
story that's always been a big thing as
well what i wanted to
just jump to quickly in terms of the
intellect of the discipline is
mccain's had this great saying that uh
ideas influence practical mean much more
than they think that madman i think he's
probably hitler hearing voices in the
air are still in their frenzy from an
academic scribbler of a generation ago
and what you see is that the neoliberal
revolution of thatcher and ray in the
80s
was reflecting developments of a decade
or more
before that the council had to encounter
revolution from coming out of chicago
economics has been moving away from that
at least for the last
25 years or so with the game theory with
down to nationality and so forth and so
in some sense the sort of pop view of
what economists think
is still well behind right the way the
profession's gone which is is
not so much
partly back to the left that in the 50s
in the post of the canadian period much
more support for intervention but also
much less certainty
much less my search has helped yourself
well this is
this is the story as in the first four
chapters of economics in two lessons but
all sorts of things can happen well i'm
looking forward to physicists being
accused of economics envy i think that
would be a perfectly
fair turn of events but okay so let's
then get on to the ways in which markets
fail and i'm sure that different people
are going to have different top 10 lists
for uh the ways in which markets fail i
have a list in front of me that i can
ask you about or is it does it make more
sense for you to just suggest your
favorite way
let me give my favorite yeah so so the
first i guess uh
the first i guess is is uh climate
change so always analogy i mean i've had
a long story about where this weird
externality comes from but too long i
think and uh
but so
essentially
the core of it is that
in the naturally emergent order of
markets
uh you can dump stuff
lots of places
carbon dioxide the atmosphere you know
sewage into rivers smoke
uh and so forth uh you don't pay for it
other people better costs and and we've
been talking about that and how to think
about that for the last hundred years or
so sure that guy named pegu was sort of
the number one man and we sort of got a
uh
we got we have quite a good
understanding of it as we say in terms
of climate change you know if you pick
20 random economists we
to address it we'd all be the same thing
we'd all do it and the problem would
have been solved a long time ago
and it's just marginal variance of
roughly speaking we'd either say look
we're going to put a price on this and
every time you burn something you have
to pay or we're going to limit the
number of amounts you can burn and
you'll have to buy a right to do it from
somebody else
uh if you want yet here's his admission
permits uh we're going to watch them off
and after that if you want to do
anything like this you'll have to have
to have a permit so that's sort of
i suppose the one that's the one that in
some sense consumes my waking hours most
but i think um
i think uh
the
next big one and probably the one that
will be here when we've either succeeded
or failed with climate change is a
landmark of as an unemployment
that labor markets don't work
in the way that they're supposed to for
the kinds of reasons that you have with
the house you only have one job
and one job you're tied to the job uh
you can't tell events what it's going to
be like
uh and um and there's all sorts of
difficulties with the the notion that
well look if there's too many of one
kind of work as their wage goes down
and so forth and we're seeing that yeah
as with the adjustment coming out the
pandemic for example that everything is
shaken up and chaotic some people are
getting substantial wage increases a lot
of people lots of people falling behind
inflation
uh things just not working not working
well and that's that's a periodic
that's a periodic value that we see that
in turn is linked to failures in
financial markets historically the worst
worst crashes have come when financial
markets have first got overheated and
then crashed we saw that the great
depression of course
and then the global financial crisis
in between we had
mostly not so bad recessions that
typically occurred
when
the central bank the fed was trying to
stop this happening and and slightly
over did the correction but the really
bad ones happen uh when when financial
markets are let run and then collapse in
the heat yeah i don't want to stop you
from listing ways in which markets can
fail but let me let me just sort of
interrogate a little bit the two that
you've mentioned here uh for climate
change
slash externalities uh i can imagine at
least two different things going on one
is just that
people are self-interested this is part
of the of the camp that we hear about uh
the market and if you can sort of
offload bad things to society and not
and not pay for it then that's the
market's doing its job but society is is
worse off but then there's also the
other fact which is that people are just
short-term thinkers right if the thing
that the they're trying to optimize is
for the next quarterly report or
whatever it is the fact that the climate
might be in trouble 100 years from now
is not going to be very relevant so are
these the same problem or two different
problems
both of those but there's a third one in
the context of something like climate
change which is
it's very hard to tell what to do i mean
there's a big movement for example
worrying about food miles how far did
your
uh how far did your tomatoes travel
to get to you
but then the question is depending on
where you live
possibly they were grown
right and yet within walking district
house but in a greenhouse
and then the question is should you go
to the greenhouse at greenhouse heated
by gas should you go to the greenhouse
and buy the locally grown uh tomatoes as
the food mileage people would say or
should you have them flown in from spain
uh where they just grow
out of the sun
out in the sun
so trying to work out
that's again the marbles of the pipe
yeah the mars the price mechanism as
opposed to central planning so with the
early pollution problem smoke you just
said you're pouring smoke out of this
chimney stop
or put a scrubber in
um
with something like sulfur dioxide
things like sulfur dioxide and carbon
dioxide almost impossible to get to zero
so you have to say you know we then move
to these permit type solutions
and if we can uh you know economists
haven't had much excess persuading it
but but this problem
goes beyond
this kind of issue of how
of
people not doing the right thing of one
way or another and simply saying without
a market it's very hard to tell what the
right thing to do actually is well i
guess this was going to be my next
question because for climate change i
can imagine
the government passing laws that say
don't pollute or don't pollute more than
this amount or i can imagine
implementing a policy that just adds
extra costs to polluting right yeah if
you pollute this much we're going to
charge you this much and in the latter
case
it's still the market that is finding
the answer it's just that you're you're
sort of nudging it a little bit
well it's a corrected market and this is
where i think you've seen a split
uh
particularly among you know i used to
term propertarians but you might say
libertarians
that lots of them hate this idea and the
reason they hate it is is some of them
love it and some of them hate it the
reason people who love it say here's a
market we've created necessary property
rights we don't need government coming
in telling us
buy this tomato with that tomato
the cost of the carbon will be in the
tomato in the price of tomato just do
what you want but there's a bunch of
people out there who have this creation
story of property rights that somehow
rather they emerge without the state and
if you say
if if then they say uh here's this newly
minted property right just like your
your car you can trade your car
for for a carbon permit where the carbon
permit come from it came from this piece
of legislation right here
where'd your car come from well
something more complicated but back in
the day
uh all those rights were created because
kings and states said you can have this
and you can't have that
and in addition your right to your car
is no different from your right to your
social security
or
somebody uh somebody on welfare's right
to government support they've all been
created by the state
and
and now it's
yeah
yeah yeah we've got that out the way
let's look at what we should do with
markets yeah and this goes back to i
guess this values versus efficiency kind
of justification for
being pro market right but but even if
you're purely on the efficiency side or
forget the word even if we're on the
purely efficiency side do economists
have a feeling that
market-based solutions to climate change
like charging people money for polluting
are usually better than just banning
polluting or something like that or is
it more complex uh
i think in the case of climate change
uniformly so
so yeah if it's
dumping sign under the river you just
say no no cyanide don't dump it in the
river
but if you're saying
uh yeah if you're saying every moment
that you're doing something yeah where
you here we are
using our talking on there yeah a
relatively low intensity activity but
we've both got computers running
we might have something happening in our
house
and i mean although it turned out to be
wrong yeah there was a calculation
floating about back in the day that
claimed that data centers and things
were consuming gigantic amounts of
electricity and yeah and we can't tell
the only way to tell yeah there's no way
that any central planner can work out
uh
i can work out
at that level at that level of saying in
every single thing you do where it
really would be
a level of central planning more
comprehensive than simply saying this is
how many computers you can have and so
forth and so so the market the market
solution is the best one and we've ended
up we end up with sort of a series of
half market half
half three yeah half-baked kinds of
things at australia for example we have
a
a system of renewable energy credits
which specifically applies to
electricity and create a kind of market
for
for carbon dioxide emissions
and we have a bunch of a bunch of other
very half bank sorts of ways of bringing
these calculations into play
uh and then yeah and then civil society
is kind of doing this also by
leaning on banks and saying you know if
you lend money to
if you lend money to a confirmed power
station we're going to turn up at your
atm and give you grief and so that's
some of them say we won't and others say
well we've got this market to ourselves
but
we can't diversify we'll charge you two
or three percent more and that's enough
to to put them out of business so yeah i
think on the israel climate change i
would say the economics profession is
more unified than almost any other topic
more unified around the idea of just
making it prohibitively expensive to
pollute in these ways yes through the
market and and let the market decide how
to get around that whether it's building
electric cars
yeah as we reduce yeah as reducer what
are what are the most yeah what are the
most important uses of putting carbon
dioxide the ones we need to give up last
exactly and for the labor market stuff
um
how
do can i interpret that as
the fact that the people who are in the
labor market are real people who you
know might have some
attachment to their location or their
job or or their training or whatever
like in some sense does it come down to
the fact that people are not infinitely
fungible and and uh
are able to switch effortlessly
there's that so there's there's the um
uh yeah there are information problems
yeah if
boss comes around and says uh
you know if things are really bad in the
market uh i'm going to need you all to
take a five percent cut in your wages
um
yeah
well
the boss has not been intended to say
that at any time
and so and so you're going to resist
there are all kinds of problems uh with
how labor markets work and i should say
on the contrary of um
of um
and then and then there's sort of macro
problems of of the economy being out of
equilibrium and so we have yeah i should
say
having said
having said uh the general equilibrium
theory doesn't have an
equilibrium
approach
the the real story i suppose that as the
white as things develop for most of the
period after world war ii is we have one
theory of how markets worked in this
sort of abstract
price equilibrium way another theory
keynesian macroeconomics which said uh
except that they might fall in the heap
and fail fail to clear and the attempts
to integrate those two have consistently
failed right and so
this is an issue where
the exact opposite was about climate
change economists are utterly disunified
so there's one bunch saying
essentially the general elected
equilibrium story is right if only
governments would stop putting their ore
in
everything will be right if you see
fluctuations that aren't caused by
governments there are optimal responses
so called real business cycles and so
forth and another bunch essentially
saying um with very modest
qualifications
uh the story of the code's job was right
uh that um
that government policy has a big and
systematic effect on things like
inflation and unemployment and the best
way to understand that is in terms of
notions like aggregate and for a while
the two caps seem to have reconciled my
previous book zombie economists a whole
lot about this they seem to reconcile
on something called new canes in
economics
but the global financial crisis really
blew that up
and so now we have now we have again
a division between
people essentially saying yes
governments systematically affect the
rate of unemployment inflation and
within that an argument of
did we simulate too much or too little
and then another bunch of people left
they're readily saying yeah you can't it
doesn't work
uh people wake up and in the end
governments can only really create
inflation well there's a whole
different angle of critique of the
market which maybe you were going to get
to when i interrupted you but just that
it leaves people behind so readily right
just kind of heartless is there a more
emotional or uh you know welfare state
liberal kind of critique that we should
put on the table well well there's two
bits to this one which is in my book
very much is
i said you know the market reaches this
equilibrium
uh which is brazil yeah in the ideal
case has no free lunches we can't make
you better off without making somebody
else worse off
but that leaves entirely open the
question of uh who who should get what
in the first place
and opportunity cost applies to that
also that at something which which gives
me more rights
uh gives somebody else less rights if if
workers
if workers own their jobs in some sense
uh
employers have less employers have less
ownership of their capital and vice
versa
and um
so and so so that allocation problem is
subject to logic of opportunity cost
and is um
and is uh and yeah so so in some sense
the left behind notion is uh
is part of that is the idea that workers
own their jobs to some extent and we use
a possessive even though of course
uh certainly in the u.s with employment
at will it works they have no property
rights no jobs roughly speaking um
and i've been
that's even not quite sure in the u.s
under budget yeah but that's roughly
speaking the story is even though you
call it your job
it's no more your job than uncle's top
cat and who tom's cabin was actually his
cabin
and
similarly to the to the climate change
question i i can imagine distinguishing
between government regulations like
for worker safety right like the factory
has to obey certain things and that that
seems to be fairly characterized as an
intervention in the market whereas
if we just you know tax people an
enormous amount tax the rich and then
give the money to the poor in some
universal income or something like that
that still is
within those constraints the market is
still going to find its equilibrium
right
yeah so this is a great distinction here
a great distinction that jacob hacker
makes between pre-distribution how we
set the property rights in the first
place
and redistribution which is is doing
afterwards and
so to the extent that they're solidified
into the market in in this distinction
our taxes go in with with uh with
regulations as redistribution uh through
oh the previous question is what about
things like union rights
if if workers have presumptive right to
join a union
and the employers are obliged bargaining
with them that creates one set of labor
market outcomes and those are best
thought of as as property rights
occurring before the market before the
market opens
as opposed to saying after after market
open after we've got the market outcomes
we'll take some of the money and give it
to other people uh
but yeah i underlined that though is
certainly
and this isn't hard and fast that
undoubtedly your right to social
security is a kind of property right
uh
so um so the distinction can be made in
different ways but um but it is an
important one and and where the market
works
the scope of the market is there i
suppose the other point which i want to
come back to with marcus leaving
with disillusion with markets is the
question of how much scope the market
should have or should you be able to
sell your kidney
for example uh there's a uh
propertarian blog which has a segment
saying markets and everything which more
or less implicitly takes the view the
more things are subject to the market uh
the better and very clearly you know
against that i suppose there's a left
critique of decommodification that says
uh
in the
goes away from a central planning kind
of notion and says sure look when we go
to the supermarket
uh
we go supermarket we want to um yeah we
just want to look at supermarket people
what we want but for example when we
decide well should we have a supermarket
or a corner store uh that we shouldn't
have the market deciding that kind of
outcome
i guess this goes once again back to you
know a more
normative value-based distinction um
and i guess the pro-market people
would worry about paternalism from the
government right trying too hard to
protect people from themselves and they
would say just on philosophical grounds
let them sell their kidney if they want
to but that does kind of presume a kind
of
rationality and responsibility on the
part of the individual agents which
might sometimes be true and sometimes
not well also of course um you know i
can't imagine that bill gates is going
to be selling his kidney anytime soon
and so um so the question yeah the
a lot of questions uh
uh come back to this question of
distribution that yeah um
that broadly speaking in a um i mean
it's not the only question that arises
and for example with blood with blood
supply for example there's always lots
of complications about it going in
different directions but so you get very
complicated stories uh but a lot of it
is a lot of it's a question of what
happens to equality inequality when
these things
and i'm sure we could keep listing
failures and ways that markets can fail
but
you you hinted at the the existence of
these sort of booms and busts right uh
bubbles and crashes
and the
there have been various arguments i
haven't followed them maybe you can fill
us in that
oh we figured that out there aren't
going to be any more booms and busts but
they haven't they clearly empirically
have not gone away they're they're as
bad as ever
yes and so um uh if there's uh
rogue and ride i'm not right here
kendrick for any one of the authors
israel from reinhardt have this story
this time is different
uh
looking at yeah at every time any at
every point we believe this
uh that include that uh that we have a
new economy here uh uh you can see these
predictions come again and again
the longest and most credible version of
this was that the keynesian boom period
of
50s 60s and so forth when again we
thought we had everything solved
um things went wrong we gave up on that
so i suppose obviously we could do a lot
better if we went back to broadly
speaking that understanding of the world
but certainly
certainly i think um
look
i would say uh
we've had a series of demonstrations in
the past 30 years first the dot-com
bubble and bust
then the global financial crisis and
then you know piling observation on
observing crypto is sort of
uh i think
has to be the ultimate refutation of um
of any notion of market efficiency that
at this point no i mean there's a sort
of pious hope that somehow
a database technology that's been around
for 30 years and has no use no actual
applications
will magically turn out to be valuable
simply because there's a huge amount of
money associated with it i mean if if
people have bet a trillion dollars
on object-oriented programming i imagine
there'll be
fastly yeah there it goes
this i don't know much about it other
than um well other than
the interesting observation apparently
all of the
of cryptocurrency use relational
databases
for their internal
in celebration anyway whole thing is
worthless
and at this point the idea that's going
to be used
in order transactions have been given up
it's valuable because it's valuable
people understand look the only thing
this reports is
somebody did a complicated calculation
which is of no interest to anybody
but yeah
it's it's been valuable and and
no one of significance in the financial
markets has held out against i mean
warren buffett said it's rubbish
individual people have but
uh until relatively recently you can say
look this stuff is happening because
a bunch of silly people get together and
do this stuff we can't stop them but now
a city bank of all these people they're
all yeah if they're all into it right so
you can reasonably say no no financial
institution has simply said
uh
this stuff
is is useless
sooner related grief will come
we won't deal with it
by all means go to one of our
competitors if you want to do this stuff
uh
but yeah when you lose all your money
maybe you'll think
well definitely no one's done that yeah
i'm not an expert either in
cryptocurrency and i know that opinions
get very heated um
i i could have imagined that uh a use
for cryptocurrency
really as currency like just as you know
a way of keeping track of transactions
um but clearly something that is wildly
impossible to predict its value isn't
very good as a currency and so my my
very simplistic understanding is it just
became valuable because people thought
it was valuable and if there's no there
there this is warren buffett's
criticism like if if suddenly people
change their mind all of that wealth has
disappeared and that's not what we
should be about
and there's a false argument to the
effect of all what about gold and what
about paper currency
and so here gold's easy the answer is
that
gold isn't in much use of currency if it
were abolished completely
there would still be gold mines gold
yeah it's pretty right it uh can be used
for computer connections it's true that
because yeah having having to establish
people like this stuff
the fact that we can use this money
means there's more demand for it so the
price of gold is higher than it would be
it was just just something you use for
ornaments and filling teeth and stuff
like that but without the underlying
value it can't be done we pay for money
it's very straightforward there's a
government
with guns
they say
you will pay us taxes and they say
in the us if you bring us enough
pictures of presidents
we'll regard your
obligations as discharged
uh and and indeed yeah uh
in place in africa where they didn't
have money that was precisely what they
they came in they wanted people to work
for wages instead of being
hunter-gatherers
so they said you've got a hut here
that will cost you a shilling a year
where do you get a shilling
go and work for the european planter
because they have shillings
and so so both so-called fiat money and
gold have a real underlying value if you
look at
uh if you look at crypto what you see is
the answer is somebody
performed very complicated calculation
you can't
you don't even get the answer
calculation you can't sell it
uh
if if you think so it wouldn't matter if
people stopped believing in money
as long as when the government came came
to collect their taxes they paid up yeah
and so
this leads us to i mean the crypto
example is an example of a relatively
new technology here and uh the other
point that you want to make which i
definitely want to give you time to uh
explain is this shift economically from
properties and goods to information and
how this is affecting things i mean
maybe the whole
financial crisis sort of uh
prefigures this in some way uh because
finance i would say financial crisis
have been around for a long time of
course so that that um
yeah but yeah so what i wanted so so
when i was at school partly an
australian economist pioneered this
stuff but we learned about a three
section of the economy and roughly
speaking to a bunch of people primary
producers who were particularly result
of the earth and they either dug stuff
up or grew it then there were
manufacturers who were pretty good who
turned this stuff into cars and loaves
of bread and and things uh then there
were
a tertiary sector which basically was uh
fat warehouses shops
all these kinds of things that were and
then off on the side there were some
bits that didn't really fit in like
university lecturers and
stuff like that
there were few enough in number that
that they could they could more sp lord
and so and the whole concept of gdp in
fact
the crucial aspect of gdp is to make
sure we don't count the
uh the wheat multiple times as it goes
from being produced on the farm to being
a loaf of ready now
we make sure that each stage we only
look at the value add so that was what
the economy was like
and
at one time yeah the manufacturing one
time the agricultural sector was largest
then the manufacturing sector was
largest in the service center was
largest but it was still all essentially
to do with getting goods in our hands
but now the majority of the economy and
all the action is in information what
we're doing right now i mean the if you
look at if you look at the economy we're
doing okay there's some bits of
equipment involved
um
but uh yeah the the
value of the time you know
as judged by the market yeah the value
of my wages compared to the value of my
computer is is gigantic uh the compute
the computer part the hardware part of
the industry has been shuffled off
mostly into a relatively small wall
story all the action is is information
and coming back to market failures
information is a public good uh that is
yeah i i give you the i do this podcast
you put on the internet
uh it's not perfect because you can't
say you can pay wallet but the point is
it is
we have this notion of a magic pudding
cut and coming in as many people as one
can listen to podcasts it doesn't
degrade it's infinitely useful
and that in turn means
uh
there's a price it's can you stick a
barrier in front of it that doesn't
deter lots and lots of people from
getting it but
gives you money that doesn't bear any
real relation to opportunity cost some
things which are very valuable can't be
kept quiet can't be controlled
uh and they're gone
uh other things of less value and other
points of best value in the system like
search for example
uh can be controlled and marketed and so
so we have a situation where
google is immensely valuable
most the content that the google
searches on
uh is underwater is entirely unrewarded
so that's the sort of
and and the other feature of this is
that there's very little need yeah so
there's no relationship between
what you what you produce and what value
is and that in turn means
that there's no real return to capital
anymore so google of course they've got
some they've got some yeah a big bank
yeah
large amounts of computers but the cuts
of what they have is first first mover
position in the search market
sometime back in the 1990s they they
developed a somewhat better search
engine than than their earlier arrivals
it hasn't yeah hasn't really improved i
mean it certainly hasn't improved from
the point of view of somebody who just
wants to search for
non-market-related information it's
probably got worse
but
but it's very hard to replicate there's
no real need to
and so what you've seen is
that the rates of private investment are
falling that's reflected in very low
rates of of interest
people are confused because of you know
monetary policy and the fed doing this
in the short run but the big story is
long run rates of interest have fallen
to zero in real terms so google can
borrow money indefinitely in the future
at two percent which is what we expect
inflation to be the u.s government every
u.s government governments can do this
uh we have these really low rates of
interest reflecting the fact that
uh investment private returns for
investment no longer really have any
close link to social utility
okay i i hear all those words but i
don't quite get the connection i mean i
completely get the fact that these super
valuable companies are valuable not
because of their stuff
but because of some handle on knowledge
and rights and
access and whatever so that's a
different kind of valuation so but where
do the interest rates come in why is it
that google can get away with a small
interest well the answer is the answer
now is if you want it yet the answer now
is if you want to
if you want to uh
if you want to
develop growing things in the economy
you don't put a lot of money into
capital investment absolutely not in
physical capital um
what you do is
uh find a bit of find a business
information economy that hasn't been
hasn't been pinched off yet and find a
way of
fencing it off i mean that roughly
speaking is what what google did 30
years ago
or you find something you can give away
and attach advertising to which is what
facebook and twitter do
um
so so the uh what you have a situation
where the uh once you once you've
established the position
the um
the uh
you don't really need much in the way
any kind of capital not even r d you
know if you even when you throw in
google's r d it really isn't
isn't that much yeah what you need is is
is something in the information sphere
that you can sell
and so so what that means is
in this in the in the growing parts of
the economy there's very little need for
capital investment to deliver it
meanwhile the old manufacturing part of
the economy has got more and more
efficient we don't need it's got smaller
relative economy as a whole
uh and so the the need for large amounts
of investment there is less and finally
though
the positive part of the story there's
these huge needs in of stuff
government's historically invested in
like health and education and so forth
which
was discouraged because
high rates of government debt high rates
of interest on government debt many
people are very worried about debt
uh
the the big story economics now is
governments really don't need to worry
nearly as much about debt as they used
to they can take on a lot more debt
and they can use it to finance socially
productive investments okay there's
still uh one step that i'm missing and
it's probably because i know nothing
about economics but again i completely
understand that google et cetera doesn't
have the same
investment in capital they don't build
factories in the way that ford motor
company would have
um but i think of interest rates
of course there's lots of different
kinds of interest rates there's interest
rates on my credit cards there's
interest rates that the uh fed charges
that banks charge each other um why does
why do the interest rates on loans or
bonds set by the federal reserve uh why
are they affected why are they lower
than they used to be
almost zero these days right sure yeah
so the first thing is yeah is the
interest rate is the opportunity cost of
time at least for uh okay and has your
credit cards good it has credit cards a
lot of the a lot of the interest rate is
chasing after deadbeat
uh borrowers and and writing off
something for loans and
ripping people off and stuff like that
but if you go to the actual operations
of the cafe market it's
i've got a dollar now
uh i'd like to consume something in a
year's time
uh how much
you know can i find somebody who can
take my dollar turns into a dollar five
say
and give me back that dollar five right
um and that's investment
and so
uh
so historically
we've been short of capital uh lots of
reasonably high high returning
investments uh
and um that sort of there's a story
which declined
over time over a very long period but
certainly as the information economy has
developed the need the number of people
who say yes give me your dollar i will
put it into a server farm
and
i'll give you back
a dollar five now
they say look
i'm spoiled for choice here i'll give
you back a dollar and two cents uh u.s
treasury for example uh gives a loan
what gives hazard bond where they say
and they're a competition in the same
market where they say we'll adjust your
money for the rate for the rate of
inflation if there's 10 inflation
between now and then we'll give you
uh the
will give you back a dollar ten
plus the interest
except that now it's minus the interest
we'll give you back the dollar ten
but the real part of the interest is
negative you'll only get a dollar nine
back because we could there are so many
people who want this that
that we can actually give you a negative
real rate of interest and that's true
for 10
20 30 years
uh zero or negative real rates of
interest and
as the combination of the information
economy doesn't need capital and
governments have have been shying away
from debt
for for many many years
uh or this has been sort of
somewhat upset by the pandemic and we'll
see how how that happens but even so
even with the pandemic and even with the
huge amounts of debt they've taken on
the stories about how
government debt is going to be ruinous
that people putting out until recently
have been essentially undermined by the
fact that because the real rate of
interest is low or negative
if governments get anywhere near
balancing their current expenditure
income uh
the debt stays the same they're not the
growth because the interest is zero the
economy grows interest four so so that
the cut you kind of panic stories you
used to see until very recently
when they do these predictions now
there's also
with a bit of inflation and uh a bit of
gdp growth uh even with big deficits the
debt's going to go
into climb and so okay i think i do get
it i think that that is actually very
helpful so the companies that are
leading our economy google or apple or
amazon or whatever they don't need to
keep building more and more factories
they don't need to keep borrowing money
to improve themselves and therefore
there's less demand for loans and
therefore the interest rate goes down
and there's another way of measuring the
same thing though it's called tobin's
cube you don't need to know the name but
roughly speaking it says
let's look at everything the company has
has built all the factories you know if
you look you go general mode you said
let's look at all their factories
ideally as i say you capitalize in their
r d
and they say here's the factories uh
then here's the market value of the
company
right and roughly speaking historically
that number was close to one and the
reason was if it was much different if
it was three say
somebody else would look at this and say
well why should they get that
i'll go and build a faction myself
another car factory
and i'll i'll get it so historic that
number was one now it's like 20. hmm
wait so remind people what the number is
what is the 20
it's the ratio of the market value of
the company to all the money that's been
invested in in the assets of the company
so the market values are just way way
bigger than what has been put into the
company yeah and so so so as it's
measured that typically means in the
case of of google it's it's the
computers and your office building that
kind of stuff they don't
they don't include r d but i've done
i've checked and r d doesn't make that
much difference so these companies are
worth
massively more than they were another
qualification is
uh you really water i suppose look at
the um
uh look at the seeks and bings and
things like that
the people who the competitors the
competitors that google's left behind
uh that value ought to be in there
somewhere but again it's not yeah again
uh not much physical capital and the r d
it wasn't wasn't gigantic and so um so
those numbers are you know that's the
other way of looking at this thing is
that the value of the company
doesn't bear much relationships the
capital invested in it and and that
and get that
in a sense precise that relationship is
why we call the system capitalism
because
uh yeah if if if the return to capital
is a is near zero and b has no
relationship to the way the economy is
working right in some sense we're
already beyond capitalism well what is
this
what we're on to is another question
good because that's my next question i'm
just going to say like if we're beyond
capitalism i mean is it just
intrinsically dangerous
or bad or is it just uncomfortable
because we don't know what's going on if
we say that uh there's the relationship
between capital and value for a
corporation has just been severed
because now all the value is in people's
heads not in brick and mortar good
question it's unsettling i would say in
the sense of it it's certainly not
it's not
so not immediately at the end of
capitalism as envisaged by socialists
and other critics it potentially could
be um yeah i can tell a story about that
um
but yeah a situation with a situation
where
most evangelists generated by
advertising uh advertising always been
this very problematic concept
um uh
uh search advertising marginal i mean
the search itself is useful but but the
advertiser so there's slots that it's a
very complicated story
uh it certainly hasn't proved to be a
system conducive to great uh equality
we've inherited in some sense the
boom in inequality
coming out of the neoliberal reforms the
80s added to that the sort of
phenomenon of tech billionaires and so
forth but there's still of course a heap
of
non-tech third generation fourth
generation
now
uh billionaires
uh
so
it's very hard to say
what what will happen other than that
a lot of the er we came back to the
moral justification a lot of kind of
theoretical justification for capitalism
uh as has existed is no longer there i
mean as as we're having this
conversation i do recognize that we're
making a podcast and i make money off it
from advertising and there's no physical
product whatsoever and uh i was at one
point offered you know
someone wanted to buy the intellectual
property of the mindscape podcast and i
didn't want to sell it in part because
it just made me nervous like what does
that mean i don't know what you're going
to do with it i certainly don't want you
to tell me what to do with it so i just
said no
well it was a fed way back when when
blogs were bigger and they went around
and added all the bloggers like crooked
timber was worth
something yeah right i mean
that's a bit worth worth an awful lot of
money right
well we should have sold probably
exactly and that's that's another aspect
of the whole information economy is
that not only can valuations go way up
but they can go way down right that it's
it's somehow
because it's not anchored to physical
stuff it is it sounds like it's
intrinsically more susceptible to booms
and busts oh well certainly yeah
certainly once
because
ultimately i mean
information wants to be free
the bust is always weight the bus is
always waiting for you um
that um
and the question yeah the question of
how do you get people to generate
information
uh becomes slight i mean for example if
this has been a
hot topic was a hot topic with covert
and the correct answer reached by the
trump administration in fact was prices
that what you say is
you give us a product and we'll give you
that we'll give you money i think in
fact
some of them are unconditional but the
ideal version is
uh yeah we won't say as we typically
have said you invent the product and
we'll give you the monopoly rights over
it to um do it and we also didn't yeah
we also needed
not only what people like universities
who have universities where they will
give you a salary
you put this stuff in the public domain
is that person but the third version
which goes back to the discovery of the
longitude
or expensive way of measuring it is you
answer this problem
and we'll give you money we'll reward
you and so that was that's one of one of
many yeah it's no it's unclear which is
the best solution but but certainly
certainly i think this comes back to
the patent solution saying we will yeah
you you register this and we'll not be
right for a certain number of years
certainly is
a way of dealing with the information
economy which looks
kind of out of date and it almost seems
too obvious to say out loud but if our
economy becomes information based then
the information in maybe a slightly
different sense that you possess
become super valuable and subject to
manipulation right i mean we're in the
middle as we're having this conversation
of elon musk maybe trying to buy twitter
or maybe not and getting in trouble
because
not letting the sec know it was going to
happen maybe saying things on twitter
that didn't match what he was doing
behind the scenes and that's just sounds
like it's going to become more and more
important to how the economy gets run
oh yeah and i mean
we have yet to see that really
delivering the goods would be my
judgment in most contexts that um they
keep on scraping up your information and
they sell it
but mostly
mostly without any obvious
smarts i mean i
i get all sorts of all sorts of
recommendations from amazon and the most
convincing is there's this book called
zombie economics and we think you really
like it
they'd love to recommend your own body
that's very accurate
um but uh yeah but um but yeah so no i
think those kinds of issues of uh yeah
given that information can't be owned
but can be useful in the short run who
who owns it who gets to control it
um
uh is a big deal
and um
i don't have a good answer right and and
maybe in that context i'll give you a
chance to return to something you said
at the beginning about bounded
rationality right i mean part of the
problem is that we don't have all the
information or we're actually subject to
misinformation but another problem is
that we're just finite and we can't know
everything even if we had access to it
no no i mean and i mean the internet has
made that a reality in a way that just
wasn't true in the past i mean when i
was a kid i read every book in the
library
i've been releasing the sort of vaguely
kids section of the library i read them
all
uh
you know you could turn on the tv and
get some feeling like what i mean low
quality information i mean information
in the sense of
burning rubble and fed food stone but
yeah low quality data but when that was
done
yeah
once they went home to the stuff if you
weren't interested in that was that it
was back to re-reading your library
books in there you can't possibly um
you know to look at the internet you
know you run through
looks interesting won't get to it listen
to it get to it
maybe i don't just read the headline on
this one um
so that that that boundedness has become
an absolute reality uh for everybody in
a way that just wasn't true in the past
and
yeah i think some people are handling it
better than others
i mean the question of hat what fuels
you apply
uh
is uh you know just a diff yeah a skill
that we have yet to learn
and
maybe we'll get through the current mess
and learn well maybe not well i guess
maybe as a final topic to touch on i do
want to give you the opportunity to sort
of give your proactive recommendations
for for what we need to take seriously
in this situation that you've outlined
with the
the need for public investments in
things that the market is not going to
naturally do especially in this
information economy
yeah so i think as a classic uh
human capital services what's in
people's heads and making sure their
bodies support them health and education
is is a big deal that um and all this
ultimately comes out of people's heads
and and
and yeah we i mean
i could give yeah
education everywhere is this huge
problem but of course in the us
just financing the whole structure this
gigantic problem yeah there are ways to
fix it but they're going to involve a
fairly substantial outlet of public
money and then then it has to be done
right so yeah that sort of i mean but
things things like free community
college for example would be one
yeah an easy one um whether yeah but so
that's the zest aspect of it but then i
think
what we ideally want which is going to
be very difficult
is for governments to take
responsibility for providing lots of
free and reliable information in a way
that
and
that requires solving a bunch of social
problems i mean yeah in some countries
that
that wouldn't be that difficult a
question in the us
obviously the most basic facts are in in
disputes so the idea of you know i mean
even
obviously for example publishing the
results of the 2020 presidential
election that's the kind that
governments have historically done um
when you when you can't do that then the
question of trying to solve
trying to solve the more general problem
of
uh dealing with this
information and fighting with access to
it is even more problematic but i
suppose
that
nonetheless
if if that was if that responsibility
were taken more generally more seriously
and seen as a central part of what
government agencies
what governments were doing
we could get a lot more useful stuff
than we have i think well okay i mean
let me this sounds good but maybe a bit
utopian so let me just push back on it
uh for purposes of of fretting and
worrying i mean
putting aside the political polarization
weirdness and and
reality based uh community and so forth
are you recommending that the government
just offer more information to people or
somehow help people decide which
information is true and which
information is false
ultimately uh ultimately i mean
yeah
and on the assumption that the
government remains more or less on the
side of sanity of the information and
then uh yeah and then in some sense
there has to be a social consensus which
may or may not survive that uh
yeah if i see something
well clearly is not a consensus a
majority viewpoint that if i see
something on the noaa
something from the national ocean air
things about climate change that that
information is like to be reliable uh
and and
and i can make the information usually
available but also um i mean i'm
thinking of a more
general program systematically putting
all the stuff that's in the public
domain
on the internet and the way that the
gutenberg project tried to do
there's lots of stuff like that that
governments uh governments could do
if they saw that as part of their role
just saying you know here is all this
information out there which could be
made available and we're going to put
actual resources to make it about yeah i
mean every time everything you're saying
sounds wonderful and recent experiences
in the country where i live uh make me
skeptical that it will be easy to pull
off because we don't even we're not even
happy letting people
study the climate or climate change and
or the effects of guns and things like
that but that's okay let's put that
aside i mean is the motto
is it too simplistic to say that the the
final motto is
in the information economy um one of the
most important public services
is spreading information widely
inaccurately
yeah and also of course paying the
generation of information which is good
possible research
and stuff like that and surprisingly
more research is needed is the
fewer all researchers but yeah but all
sorts of stuff like that uh
recognizing the value of it that uh even
when it can't easily be captured
and tried to make it easily easily
accessible available that i think is
yeah
yeah i mean google
does that in a very half-baked kind of
way finding a really good yet the task
of finding a search engine given the
problem of bias
is an interpreter one perhaps but
but certainly there
there's i think a lot more room for the
public sector to put into
uh making information available
educating people so they have the skills
to
uh to interpret and use it is is the
future of the economy so i guess the
motto really is information is a public
good and we should take it seriously as
one yeah
all right
i like that message and i think i've
understood something about interest
rates that i never did before so john
quicken thanks very much for being on
the windscape podcast thank you
[Music]
you